acetic acid is an example of a weak acid
and sodium hydroxide is an example of a
strong base if we are titrating a sample
of acetic acid with sodium hydroxide
acetic acid would be the analyte the
substance that we are analyzing and
sodium hydroxide would be the titrant
when acetic acid reacts with sodium
hydroxide the products are an aqueous
solution of sodium acetate and water
next let's look at the complete or
overall ionic equation for this reaction
because acetic acid is a weak acid it
does not ionize completely in aqueous
solution therefore for our complete
ionic equation we simply write acetic
acid we don't show it as being ionized
however sodium hydroxide is a strong
base that dissociates one hundred
percent in aqueous solution therefore we
would show it as its ions n a plus and o
h minus
since sodium acetate is a soluble salt
an aqueous solution it would consist of
sodium cations and the acetate anion we
would also include water in our overall
or complete ionic equation
for our net ionic equation we leave out
spectator ions since sodium cations are
on the left and the right side when we
take those out we're left with the net
ionic equation for this weak acid strong
base titration so acetic acid reacts
with hydroxide anions to form the
acetate anion and water
next let's look at the titration curve
for our weak acid strong base titration
ph is on the y-axis and since we're
adding our strong base to our solution
of weak acid milliliters of base added
is on the x-axis let's use particulate
diagrams to help us figure out what's
going on in this titration keep in mind
that these particulate diagrams are only
meant to represent what's going on in
the solution during the titration and
water molecules will be left out for
clarity looking at our first particulate
diagram there's only acetic acid present
only two particles of acetic acid
present therefore this is before any
base has been added so on our titration
curve we're right here at zero
milliliters of base added next let's add
some sodium hydroxide to our initial
solution of acetic acid
so for sodium hydroxide the pink sphere
represents a sodium cation so we think
about adding in the sodium cation and
also a hydroxide anion
remember from our net ionic equation
hydroxide anion reacts with acetic acid
to form the acetate anion and water
since water is left out of our
particulate diagrams we don't see it
here in this second particulate diagram
however we do see the acetate anion that
formed when the hydroxide anion reacted
with the acetic acid particle
in the second particular diagram we also
see the sodium cation that was added and
also the particle of acetic acid that
was present initially because we started
with two particles of acetic acid and we
have only one left in the second
particular diagram that means that half
of the initial acid has been neutralized
so this second particulate diagram is
meant to represent the half equivalence
point in the titration
next let's add enough sodium hydroxide
to neutralize the other half of acid
that was initially present in solution
the acetic acid particle reacts with the
hydroxide anion to form water and the
acetate anion since water's left out of
our particulate diagram we don't see
water in this third particulate diagram
however we do see the acetate anion that
was formed we also see the sodium cation
that was added and at the half
equivalence point we already had a
sodium cation and an acetate anion and
so we can see those in our third
particulate diagram as well if we
compare the third particulate diagram to
the first particulate diagram all of the
acid that was initially present has been
neutralized therefore the third
particulate diagram represents the
equivalence point of the titration we
can estimate the equivalence point on
our titration curve by looking for the
area where we see a sharp increase in ph
so right about in here and if we draw a
little line about halfway up that line
approximately is a good place to mark
the equivalence point
so this is a good estimate of our
equivalence point and if we go over to
where that intersects on the y-axis we
can estimate the ph for this weak acid
strong base titration it looks to be a
little bit over eight so between eight
and nine somewhere so the ph of the
solution at the equivalence point is
greater than seven the reason why the ph
is greater than seven is because at the
equivalence point there are acetate
anions in solution and acetate anions
react with water to form hydroxide
anions and acetic acid the ph of water
at 25 degrees celsius is 7 but because
we've increased the concentration of
hydroxide anions in solution the ph will
be greater than 7 at the equivalence
point
this is called anion hydrolysis and is
the reason why the ph is greater than 7
at the equivalence point for a weak acid
strong base titration going back to our
titration curve to the equivalence point
if we drop down to the x-axis we can see
that the equivalence point has been
reached after 50 milliliters of base
have been added so if it takes 50
milliliters of base to reach the
equivalence point it should take half
that volume to reach the half
equivalence point therefore the half
equivalence point is reached after 25
milliliters of base has been added so if
we go up here to our titration curve we
can mark the location or the approximate
location of the half equivalence point
so let me draw a line here from half
equivalence point to the point on our
titration curve let's go back to our
third particulate diagram which
represents the equivalence point and
let's add some more sodium hydroxide
into the solution
because there's no more acid present to
react with the sodium hydroxide in our
fourth particulate diagram we can see
the sodium cation and the hydroxide
anion that we added at the equivalence
point we also had two sodium cations so
here here they are in the fourth
particular diagram and two acetate
anions which are also present so the
fourth particulate diagram represents
excess base past the equivalence point
as a quick summary of our titration
curve we started out with only weak acid
so the ph was relatively low as we add
base the ph increases slowly and we get
to the half a half equivalence point
where half of the weak acid that was
initially present has been neutralized
notice how the ph is changing very
slowly in this region of the titration
curve as we continue to add more and
more base the ph increases keeps on
increasing and around the equivalence
point we see a dramatic increase in the
ph
once we go past the equivalence point
we're in the region of excess base and
the ph keeps increasing as we add more
and more hydroxide anions
during the titration of a weak acid with
a strong base a buffer solution is
actually formed so let's look in more
detail at the buffer region or the
buffer zone on our titration curve the
buffer region occurs around the half
equivalence point and we can see on our
titration curve there are very small
changes in ph as we add hydroxide anions
in this region that's because the weak
acid that's present in solution is
neutralizing the added base and
protecting against a dramatic change in
ph
we can calculate the ph at the half
equivalence point because we know at the
half equivalence point half of the
initial acid that was present has been
neutralized and turned into the
conjugate base therefore at the half
equivalence point the concentration of
weak acid is equal to the concentration
of the conjugate base we can use the
henderson-hasselbalch equation to find
the ph if the concentration of weak acid
is equal to the concentration of the
conjugate base
then the ratio of their concentrations
is equal to one and the log of one is
equal to zero therefore the ph is equal
to the pka value of the weak acid at the
half equivalence point so if we wanted
to find the pka value of a weak acid
from our titration curve we would simply
find the half equivalence point and go
over to the y-axis to estimate the pka
value because at this point the ph of
the solution is equal to the pka value
of the weak acid
next let's think about how the titration
curve can tell us about the relative
concentrations of weak acid and
conjugate base
we know that the ph is equal to the pka
value at the half equivalence point
right here on our titration curve and we
know at the half equivalence point the
concentration of weak acid is equal to
the concentration of conjugate base
therefore if we think about a point just
to the left of the half equivalence
point so right here on our titration
curve i'll call this point p
we know that the ph at that point is
less than the pka value of the weak acid
and we know that the initial point on
our titration curve was almost all weak
acid
therefore since point p is in between
the initial point where we have almost
all acid and the half equivalence point
where we have equal amounts of weak acid
and conjugate base
point p must have more weak acid than
conjugate base therefore we can say when
the ph is less than the pka value the
concentration of weak acid is greater
than the concentration of conjugate base
we could have also figured this out
using the henderson-hasselbalch equation
however it's often simpler just to think
about the shape of the titration curve
next let's think about a point just to
the right of the half equivalence point
so i'm going to call this point point q
at point q the ph of the solution is
greater than the pka value of the weak
acid so for trying to determine the
relative concentrations of weak acid and
conjugate base at point q
remember that point q
is in between the half equivalence point
and the equivalence point which is right
about here on our titration curve and at
the equivalence point there's no more
weak acid present all of the weak acid
has been neutralized and only the
conjugate base a minus remains since
point q is in between the half
equivalence point where they're equal
amounts of weak acid and conjugate base
and the equivalence point where there's
only conjugate base at point q there
must be more conjugate base
than weak acid
therefore we can say when the ph of the
solution is greater than the pka value
of the weak acid the concentration of
weak acid is less than the concentration
of the conjugate base or we could say
the concentration of conjugate base is
greater than the concentration of weak
acid finally let's talk about why a
buffer forms on this titration curve
when we first start off we have almost
all weak acid and therefore we do not
have a buffer however as base is added
to the solution the weak acid is
converted into its conjugate base and
when there are significant amounts of
the weak acid and its conjugate base we
have a buffer solution so that's right
about here on our titration curve and we
can see
the buffer is resisting large changes to
ph in this region however as we continue
to add base those the concentrations of
weak acid and conjugate base change and
eventually we no longer have a buffer
solution so the ph changes more
dramatically at this point
so the buffer region or the buffer zone
is only is only right around the half
equivalence point on our titration curve